It wasn't Amanda's dream house, it was her mom's. And it wasn't one you would usually think of as a dream house. 500 people living in a 10-story building, dorm style, right in the middle of the city.
那不是阿曼达梦寐以求的房子，那是她妈妈的梦想。而且这并不是你通常会认为的那种梦幻之家。在一个十层高的建筑里住着500个人，就像宿舍一样，就在市中心。
We were supposed to come for a four-day visit, and it turned into a two-week visit, and then a month visit. And then we lived here. So I never really got to go back and say goodbye to my friends or anything. And I was really mad at my mother for doing that to me and all this type of stuff. And I was just really mad at everybody and didn't like it here at all.
我们本来只打算去参观四天，结果变成两周，后来是一个月。最后我们就在那儿住下了。所以我从来没机会回去跟朋友们道别什么的。我当时真的很生我妈，因为她对我做了这些事，诸如此类的。我当时对每个人都非常生气，一点儿也不喜欢那个地方。
Where they moved is an experiment in communal living that, at the time, had been going on for 25 years in Chicago. Nobody owns private property, everything is shared. The TVs, the cars, everything.
他们搬去的地方是一个公共生活的实验场所，在当时，已经在芝加哥进行了25年。没有人拥有私有财产，一切都是共享的。电视、汽车，什么都是。
If you need pocket change, you go to a room called "the money office." And if they've got cash, they'll give it to you. Remember, this is 500 people.
如果你需要零花钱，你可以去一个叫“钱办公室”的房间。如果他们手头有现金，就会给你。记住，这可是500个人。
And if all this is beginning to sound like a big socialist collective in the middle of a modern American city, let me add just one more fact to make this picture complete for you. The community? It's Christian. Run by a group called Jesus People USA.
如果这一切听起来像是现代美国城市中心的一个大型社会主义公社，让我再补充一个事实来让你对这幅图景有完整的认识。这个社区？它是基督教的。由一个叫“耶稣人民美国”的团体运营。
All I did was sit up in my room and just stare out the window. I did not come down to eat or anything. I just sat there and stared out the window because I was so angry that I was just going to kill anybody that bothered me. And I did that for the first few days, like, the first three days.
我能做的就是坐在房间里盯着窗外。我没下楼吃饭什么的。我就坐在那儿盯着窗外，因为我太生气了，我觉得谁要是惹我，我就会杀了谁。头几天我都是这么干的，大概前三天吧。
At 16, a year and a half after they first moved to this community, Amanda says that she doesn't think of herself as a Christian anymore, which, understandably, upsets her mother, who moved here partly so that Amanda would live in a Christian environment and learn Christian values. It's kind of a tense subject between them.
16岁时，搬到这个社区一年半后，阿曼达说她觉得自己不再是基督徒了，这自然让她母亲很心烦。她母亲搬到这里的部分原因，就是为了让阿曼达生活在基督教环境中，学习基督教价值观。这在她们之间是个相当紧张的话题。
Like if I was in church and I didn't take Communion or something, then all that day I'd ask her questions. She's like, "I just can't think right now. I can't imagine you going to hell," and all this type of stuff. So I think she's really concerned about me, but she's just going to have to live with it.
比如如果我在教堂没领圣餐什么的，那整天我都会问她问题。她说：“我现在脑子乱得很。我无法想象你会下地狱，”之类的。所以我认为她真的很担心我，但她只能接受这个事实。
In a way, this story is not so unusual. How many of our parents move somewhere, some dream house, some vision of a new life in a new place, moving the family with them, settling new suburbs, migrating because of layoffs and divorces, and just hoping that it's going to work out for the kids in the long run? Though kids, of course, are all about the short run.
在某种程度上，这个故事并不罕见。我们有多少父母搬到某个地方，某个梦幻之家，怀着某种在异乡开始新生活的愿景，带着全家搬迁，安顿在新的郊区，因为裁员和离婚而迁移，只是希望从长远来看这对孩子有好处？当然，孩子们在意的总是短期生活。
Amanda isn't happy at the Jesus People community, but she is the exception. Most of the teenagers living there actually seem to like it a lot. And like any good parent, Amanda's mom did consult with her about the move. Amanda even agreed to move. Though, the final decision wasn't really hers.
阿曼达在“耶稣人民”社区并不快乐，但她是例外。大多数住在那里的青少年似乎都很喜欢这里。像任何好家长一样，阿曼达的妈妈确实就搬家这件事咨询过她。阿曼达甚至同意了搬家。不过，最终的决定其实并不是她做的。
That's one thing I really get angry with is I don't feel like I can make my own choices a lot of times. But that's what happens when you're 16 I guess. Everyone's like, well, that's just being a teenager. And I'm like, it stinks. I hate being a teenager.
我常感到愤怒的一点是，我觉得自己很多时候无法做出自己的选择。但我想这就是16岁时会发生的事。每个人都说，噢，这只是青少年时期而已。而我就觉得，这糟透了。我讨厌当青少年。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose some theme, invite a variety of writers, and documentary producers, and performers to tackle that theme. Today's show, Dream House. Stories about parents who had some utopian vision for their family's future and who built their dream houses to try to realize that future.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们会选定一个主题，邀请各类作家、纪录片制片人和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目是“梦幻之家”。讲述的是那些对家庭未来抱有某种乌托邦愿景，并建造梦幻之家来努力实现未来的父母们的故事。
Act One, Meema's Adventure. In that act, a family dreams of life in rural Maine, moves there, and then, well, things start to get very complicated. Act Two, Blue Sky Dream. David Beers explains the gorgeous, modern vision that drew his parents and tens of thousands of other young families to California in the '50s and '60s to work in aerospace, and what happened when they arrived. Stay with us.
第一幕，米玛的冒险。在那一幕中，一个家庭梦想着在缅因州乡村生活，搬到那里，然后，嗯，事情开始变得非常复杂。第二幕，“蓝天梦”。大卫·比尔斯解释了那个吸引他父母和数万其他年轻家庭在五六十年代来到加州从事航空航天工作的华丽、现代的愿景，以及他们到达后发生了什么。请继续收听。
Act One.
第一幕。
In 1976, Meema Spadola's parents decided to move from the Upper West Side of Manhattan, where her father was a math teacher, out of the city to build a house in Maine. It turned out to be a pivotal and redefining change in all of their lives. Meema prepared this story about her family's move. It's partly the story of her parents' dreams and partly a story of her own.
1976年，米玛·斯帕多拉的父母决定离开曼哈顿上西区——她父亲当时是一名数学老师——搬出城市去缅因州盖房子。事实证明，这成为了他们所有人生活中至关重要且重新定义人生的转变。米玛准备了这个关于她家搬迁的故事。这既是她父母梦想的故事，也是她自己的故事。
I don't have to guess at my parents' dream for our family when they moved us from New York City to Maine. They wrote it all down in a book. My mother actually wrote an entire children's story, 83 pages long. My dad did the illustrations, and I picked the title, Meema's Adventures. I was six.
当我父母把我们从纽约市搬到缅因州时，我不需要去猜他们对我们家庭的梦想是什么。他们把这一切都写进了一本书里。我妈妈实际上写了一个完整的儿童故事，足足83页。我爸爸画了插图，我给它取名叫《米玛的冒险》。那时我六岁。
"Chapter One of Meema's Adventures, At Home. Meema lived in New York City. Her apartment was on the 13th floor of a great, tall building on the windiest corner in all of the city. In the spring--"
“《米玛的冒险》第一章，在家。米玛住在纽约市。她的公寓位于全城风最大的一处街角，一座高大宏伟的大楼的第13层。春天里……”
When she wrote this the winter before we left, my mom was getting her master's degree in education. She thought that our move raised some interesting questions about early childhood development. Like, how do you help children deal with the consequences of their parents' decisions? Mom writes in the introduction, "In thinking how best to prepare my children and, indeed, my husband and myself, I came upon the idea of creating a story that we might, when the move comes, actually reenact."
当我们离开前那个冬天她写这个故事时，我妈妈正在攻读教育学硕士学位。她认为我们的搬迁提出了一些关于幼儿发展的有趣问题。比如，你如何帮助孩子应对父母决定的后果？妈妈在序言中写道：“在思考如何最好地为我的孩子，当然，还有我的丈夫和我自己做准备时，我想到了一个主意，那就是创造一个故事，等搬家的时候，我们也许可以真的演一遍。”
OK, "Chapter Four, Coming to the Mountain. The day the green pickup truck finished its long drive was sunny, cool, and breezy. The sun was setting rapidly behind the pond and over the mountains.
好的，“第四章，来到山里。绿色皮卡车结束漫长车程的那天，阳光明媚，凉爽且微风习习。太阳正迅速地在池塘后面和山顶落下。”
Mommy and daddy hoped to arrive just at this time and no later, so they could unload the truck and settle themselves nicely before dark. Of course, there was no house here yet."
“妈妈和爸爸希望正好在这个时间，而不是更晚到达，这样他们就可以在天黑前卸下卡车，安顿好自己。当然，这里当时还没有房子。”
It was raining when we arrived. The air was thick with mosquitoes. The grass was about three feet high and soaking wet. And the truck got stuck as soon as we pulled off the road.
我们到达时正在下雨。空气中满是蚊子。草大约有三英尺高，湿透了。车子刚驶离公路就陷住了。
That's my dad with the real beginning to our adventure in Maine. It was really his dream that got this started. For seven years, he'd been working as an administrator and teacher at a private school in New York. He didn't want to do that anymore. He was living the wrong life. He envisioned a homestead in the country with farm animals, gardens, maybe a windmill. Perfectly self-sustaining and efficient.
那是关于我们在缅因州探险真正开始时我爸爸说的话。这其实是他的梦想才让一切开始的。七年来，他一直在纽约的一所私立学校担任行政人员和老师。他不想再那样做了。他过着错误的生活。他设想在乡下有一个宅基地，有农场动物、花园，也许还有一台风车。完全自给自足且高效。
I had this sense that I wanted to do something in my life that I had more control over. I was feeling like I wanted to work on something that felt more like it was mine. And I suppose I really wanted to build something also, the hands-on experience of building.
我有一种感觉，我想在生活中做点自己更有掌控力的事情。我当时觉得我想从事一些让我感觉真正属于我的工作。而且我想我也真的想建造点东西，那种亲手建造的体验。
Well, dad said we could build a house. So, of course, again, coming from apartment living, build a house, I just thought that meant like a-- the wildest thing I could think of was kind of like a suburban tract house, where you come in with a key and the toilets are there, the water's set up, the plumbing, the lights, heat, walls.
嗯，爸爸说我们可以盖一所房子。所以，当然，再次重申，来自公寓生活，盖一所房子，我当时想到的最疯狂的事情就是像郊区的联排房，你拿着钥匙进去，厕所都在那儿，水接好了，管道、电灯、供暖、墙壁都有。
You never imagined--
你从来没想过——
It never occurred to me. It didn't occur to me. And I don't think it occurred to dad to mention to me, "Well, that means we have to dig a well. We have to deal with electricity." It didn't occur to me.
这从未在我脑海中浮现。确实没出现过。而且我不认为爸爸想到要跟我提起，“噢，这意味着我们必须打一口井。我们得处理电力问题。”我没想过。
Her dream of our life in Maine was this. She'd bake bread, put up preserves, raise the kids. My mom was a nice Jewish girl from the Bronx. To her, it seemed like a great idea, and it didn't seem far-fetched. Dad was a country boy. His father had built their house. He'd grown up with pigs and chickens in rural Rhode Island.
她对我们在缅因州生活的梦想是这样的。她会烤面包、做果酱、抚养孩子。我妈是一个来自布朗克斯的犹太好女孩。对她来说，这听起来是个好主意，而且看起来并不遥不可及。爸爸是个乡下男孩。他父亲盖了他们的房子。他在罗德岛乡村长大，身边有猪和鸡。
But let's make this clearer. Here was his plan. We'd live in a tent while he built a house from scratch, completely by himself, on a raw piece of land on a mountain in the middle of Maine in one summer. So that was the plan. And it didn't seem crazy at all.
但让我们把这一点说清楚。这就是他的计划。我们住在一个帐篷里，而他在一个夏天里，完全靠自己，在一片位于缅因州中部山区的原始土地上从零开始盖一所房子。这就是计划。而这看起来一点也不疯狂。
We were very clear that it was an adventure and that some people envied us. We actually thought everybody envied us. Did we ever think anybody thought we were nutty? No, we never did. But we thought people envied us.
我们非常清楚这是一次冒险，有些人羡慕我们。我们其实以为每个人都羡慕我们。我们有没有想过有人觉得我们疯了？没有，我们从来没那样想过。但我们觉得人们羡慕我们。
This whole thing was very naive. Just no concept of how our lives would change at all.
整件事非常天真。根本没有概念说我们的生活会发生多大的改变。
Our lives didn't just change. For me, it's the beginning of everything, of who I am, of who my family is today. Four years into the project, the house wasn't finished, and my parents were separated. My mother moved out. My younger brother, Emilio, and I stayed with the house, with dad. 21 years later, my mother, brother, and I live in cities, as far from rural living as you can get. My father is remarried and is the last one of us living in the house. It still isn't finished.
我们的生活不仅仅是改变了。对我来说，这是万物的起点，关于我是谁，关于我的家庭今天是谁。项目进行了四年，房子还没盖好，我的父母已经分居了。我母亲搬了出去。我弟弟埃米利奥和我留在那栋房子里，跟着爸爸。21年后，我的母亲、弟弟和我生活在城市里，离乡村生活越远越好。我父亲再婚了，是我们中最后一个住在那栋房子里的人。它至今还没完工。
OK, well, first of all, who are these people? I'm looking at dad with a moustache and Emilio as, I guess, a three-year-old or a four-year-old and it's-- is that me?
噢，好的，首先，这些人是谁？我看着留着胡子的爸爸和埃米利奥，我想大概是三四岁的时候，这是——那是我吗？
That's you. That's you.
那是你。那是你。
Wow. Wow. I'm sorry to keep saying wow, but this-- it's like who are these people?
哇。哇。抱歉我一直在说哇，但这——这简直就像这些人是谁？
I look through photos with my mom of our first summer in Maine. We seemed so optimistic and playful in these pictures, our family before the fall. Mom and dad are young, good looking, working on the building site together. Emilio and I eat breakfast outside the tent and help hammer nails. There's one of us posing proudly in front of our new outhouse.
我和妈妈翻看我们在缅因州第一个夏天的照片。在这些照片里，我们看起来如此乐观、爱玩，那是崩塌前的家庭。妈妈和爸爸很年轻，长得好看，一起在工地上工作。埃米利奥和我在帐篷外吃早餐，帮忙敲钉子。还有一张我们自豪地站在新盖的厕所前摆姿势的照片。
I remember one time, this great time, when I was working on cutting the swath through the brush to put the road in, and it was raining. It had been raining and raining for days. And things had gotten pretty muddy. And you kids were completely naked, and you were sliding around in the mud and covered with mud. And I had wanted somebody to come up to look at the possibility of doing a foundation for us. And he happened to arrive just as you kids came sliding down through the mud. He'd driven as far as he could up in his truck and got out to walk. And so he's confronted first with wet, muddy little kids screaming and laughing. And I went running past him down the path.
我记得有一次，那段美好的时光，我在修剪灌木丛，为了铺路，当时正在下雨。已经连续几天都在下雨了。地上变得相当泥泞。你们孩子们全身赤裸，在泥里滑来滑去，浑身是泥。我当时想让人过来看看能不能帮我们做地基。他刚好就在你们孩子们滑着泥巴跑过来的时候到了。他开车尽量靠近了工地，下车步行过来。所以他首先面对的是湿漉漉、满身泥巴、又叫又笑的小屁孩。我从他身边跑过去。
And naked.
而且是裸体的。
Yeah. And I came out wearing shorts and no shirt, holding my machete, and covered with little bits of leaves. Because when I'd be chopping things up with the machete, leaves would be flying all over the place. And I was wet, so they were stuck to me all over my body and my face. I had little pieces of leaves all over me. He looked a little startled.
对。我出来时穿着短裤，没穿上衣，拿着我的大砍刀，身上沾满了小叶片。因为我用大砍刀砍东西时，叶子会到处乱飞。我当时很湿，所以它们粘在我全身和脸上。我全身都是碎叶子。他看起来有点被吓到了。
I love this image of--
我喜欢这个画面——
I couldn't have been happier. If dad's dream was to have a project of his own, I had my own six-year-old dream, Little House on the Prairie. And I'm not talking about that horrible TV series. I mean the books that Laura Ingalls Wilder wrote about her family's experience of moving West, building a home, and surviving blizzards, droughts, marauding wolves, and illnesses.
我当时再幸福不过了。如果爸爸的梦想是拥有一个属于自己的项目，那我也有我六岁的梦想，《草原小屋》。我指的不是那个糟糕的电视剧。我指的是劳拉·英格斯·怀德写的关于她家庭搬往西部、建立家园、在暴风雪、干旱、狼群和疾病中生存的经历的书。
In New York, I'd been obsessed with the Little House books and would act out scenes from them with friends. In Maine, I got to play Laura every day. I saw everything through the filter of the Little House books. I'd pick blueberries up on the mountain, and mom would make a batch of pancakes over the camp stove. Dad would cut two by fours for the house, and I'd stand by and hand him nails. I felt like I had arrived.
在纽约，我一直对《草原小屋》系列书着迷，并会和朋友们一起表演书中的场景。在缅因州，我每天都能扮演劳拉。我通过《草原小屋》书籍的滤镜看待一切。我会在山上采蓝莓，妈妈会在露营炉上做一堆煎饼。爸爸会为房子切割木料，我就会站在旁边帮他递钉子。我觉得我终于到家了。
OK, so in my mythology of our summer, the summer of '76, it was like you were Pa, Laura's Pa, and I was Laura. And it was like you were being this pioneer man. You were a big hero, and I was the little helper. That's what I felt like.
好的，所以在关于我们那个夏天的神话里，那年夏天是76年，就像你扮演爸爸，劳拉的爸爸，而我是劳拉。就像你是一个先驱男人。你是一个大英雄，而我是小助手。这就是我的感觉。
Well, that's not that far from the truth. I think a lot of people thought of me as a big hero for doing this. Our friends in New York City thought it was an extraordinary adventure. And I was probably the only one who didn't think I was a hero. I was filled with anxiety that I wasn't telling anybody about because I realized that I had undertaken a pretty near impossible task.
嗯，那离事实不远。我想很多人认为我做这件事是一个大英雄。我们在纽约市的朋友认为这是一次非凡的冒险。我可能是唯一一个不认为自己是英雄的人。我充满焦虑，我没告诉任何人，因为我意识到我承担了一项几乎不可能完成的任务。
When I was writing Meema's Adventures, it was before we did it. So the time frame is totally wacky and unrealistic.
当我写《米玛的冒险》时，是在我们做这件事之前。所以时间框架完全是荒谬和不现实的。
"Chapter Six, Moving In. Meema opened her eyes. Outside the tent, birds were singing their cheery morning wake-up songs, while inside the tent, Meema lay snuggled in her sleeping bag. She was thinking about the day ahead. Today, they would finally move into the new house.
“第六章，入住。米玛睁开了眼睛。帐篷外，鸟儿们唱着欢快的晨间唤醒曲，而帐篷内，米玛依偎在睡袋里。她在思考接下来的一天。今天，他们终于要搬进新家了。”
The morning was cool and sunny with summer in its last days in Maine. Soon the tent would--"
“那天早晨凉爽晴朗，是缅因州夏天的最后日子。很快帐篷就会……”
In fact, when summer was in its last days, we had only a hole in the ground. There was no floor, no walls, no roof, no house.
事实上，当夏天快要结束时，我们只有一个地洞。没有地板，没有墙壁，没有屋顶，没有房子。
When I look back now, I think the moment the ominous music starts is here.
现在回顾过去，我觉得预示不祥的音乐从这里开始响起。
Do you remember-- not to bring up sad stuff. But do you remember Jamie, the puppy?
你还记得吗——不是为了提伤心事。但你还记得杰米，那只小狗吗？
Yeah, you mean the one I ran over. He was sleeping under the truck. I started it up, and he didn't wake up, and I didn't know he was there. I felt pretty bad about it.
是的，你是说那只被我压死的小狗。他当时睡在卡车下面。我发动了车，他没醒，我也不知道他在那儿。我对那件事感觉很糟糕。
It just seemed like this was like the first tragedy of the summer or something. It was like something that seemed so nice had gone very wrong.
这似乎是那个夏天第一场悲剧什么的。感觉原本看起来那么美好的事情变得非常糟糕。
Yeah. I feel sad thinking about it now.
是的。现在想到它我还是觉得难过。
This is from Chapter Seven, At Home Again. "Winter evenings in the new house were cozy and warm. Mommy and daddy had finished building the stone fireplace, so now, after dinner every night, they all settled in the living room. The warmth and color of its fire cheered and relaxed everyone. The bright new wood--"
这是第七章，再次在家。 “新房子里的冬夜舒适温暖。妈妈和爸爸盖好了石壁炉，所以现在，每天晚饭后，他们都坐在客厅里。火的温暖和颜色让每个人都感到愉快和放松。明亮的新木材……”
In reality, when the first snow came on October 3, we were still living in the tent. And believe me, there was nothing cozy about it. The only thing we could do was set up camp in the unfinished house.
实际上，当10月3日第一场雪落下时，我们还住在帐篷里。相信我，那一点也不舒服。我们唯一能做的就是搬到还没完工的房子里去安营扎寨。
There were no windows. There were window openings cut, but no windows. And the openings were covered with plastic.
没有窗户。虽然锯开了窗洞，但没有窗子。窗洞都用塑料布遮盖着。
The fourth wall was plastic, right?
第四面墙是塑料布，对吧？
Oh, that's right. That's right. On the south side. Not a very secure house. And impossible to heat. It was just a shell, really.
噢，没错。没错。在南侧。不是一栋很安全的房子。而且根本无法取暖。它实际上只是一个外壳。
And it already had started to snow, and I got kind of concerned because we were going to sleep immediately after dinner, and all us were wearing hats, and gloves, and coats, and scarves. I felt like we were hibernating.
天已经开始下雪了，我有点担心，因为我们晚饭后马上就要睡觉，我们所有人都戴着帽子、手套、外套和围巾。我觉得我们像是在冬眠。
Mom said something about feeling like she would come home from work, and we would all eat, and then we were all dressed in our coats, and our hats, and our mittens. And we would just get into bed, and it was like we were hibernating.
妈妈说过感觉就像她下班回家，我们大家一起吃了饭，然后我们都穿上了外套、帽子和连指手套。我们就直接上床睡觉了，就像我们在冬眠一样。
Oh, that's interesting. I don't remember. I honestly don't remember.
噢，真有趣。我不记得了。我真的不记得了。
I would drive home from work through Camden and on the way home to Lincolnville. And I would see the lights. 4 o'clock, 4:30 in the afternoon, lights would start coming on in the houses. It sort of felt like I was out of Dickens or something. Oh, a house. A real home.
我会开车从工作地点经过卡姆登回林肯维尔的家。我会看到灯光。下午4点、4点半，灯光在房子里亮起来。那种感觉就像我出自狄更斯的小说一样。噢，一栋房子。一个真正的家。
And it started getting cold, and we decided-- well, really, mom pushed this wisely-- that we should not go any further without getting another place for the winter.
而且天气开始变冷，我们决定——说实话，妈妈睿智地推动了这件事——如果不为冬天找另一个地方，我们就不能再继续下去了。
I just felt like it's really important, I think, that we find a place where we can have a cabin and really have warmth and light. It didn't need to be necessarily electric stuff, but a closed-up house.
我只是觉得，能找到一个我们可以有小木屋，真正有温暖和光亮的地方，我认为这非常重要。不需要一定是电器的东西，而是一个封闭的房子。
Yeah, that's not a lot to ask.
是的，那要求并不高。
Well, at that point, it kind of felt like it was being a little bit of a lot to ask.
嗯，在那个时候，感觉这稍微有点要求过高了。
It was impossible to stay. We moved out of the house to a small summer cabin a few miles away. The pipes there were frozen, so there was no running water.
待在那里是不可能的。我们从房子搬到了几英里外的一个小度假小屋。那里的水管冻住了，所以没有自来水。
A word now about where this adventure took place. Searsmont, Maine. Population 500. You've never heard of it. You didn't go to camp there. Don't think L.L. Bean in Kennebunkport. Think Appalachia, hardscrabble, not quaint. And my dad's plan in the middle of this was to do everything himself.
现在说说这次冒险发生的地方。缅因州西尔斯蒙特。人口500。你肯定没听说过。你没去过那里的夏令营。别把它想成肯尼邦克波特的L.L. Bean。把它想成阿巴拉契亚，艰难困苦，一点也不古雅。而我爸爸在中途的计划是事必躬亲。
At one point, he spent a week at the bottom of a 30-foot hole with a pickax trying to dig a well. We didn't have electricity or a phone then. Nothing came easy here.
有一次，他花了一个星期在一个30英尺深坑的底部，拿着镐头试图打一口井。当时我们没有电，也没有电话。这里什么都不容易。
Sometimes when people go after a dream like this, they make an innocent decision for innocent reasons that has profound consequences.
有时当人们追求这样的梦想时，他们会因为单纯的原因做出天真的决定，却带来深远的影响。
I wanted a view. And I just thought, well, I just didn't understand what difference it would make. But I think everyone was a mite surprised that we built right up the farthest spot up on the hill, just really way up. And that's where dad fit right in. He indulged those fantasies. Because he's like, "Hey, great idea. Sure, we can build up there."
我想要一个视野。我当时只是认为，嗯，我不明白会有什么不同。但我想每个人都有些惊讶我们盖在山上最远的地方，真的是非常高的地方。而那正是爸爸符合的地方。他放纵了那些幻想。因为他就像，“嘿，好主意。当然，我们可以在上面盖。”
Let me explain because this might not seem like a big deal. A view means back from the road, which in our case means back from the road, past the field, up through the brush and trees, on the side of the mountain. Which means a really long driveway. And when I say driveway, it doesn't exactly capture this. There should be another word for what this was.
让我解释一下，因为这看起来可能不是什么大不了的事。视野意味着远离道路，在我们的情况下，意味着远离道路，越过田野，穿过灌木丛和树木，在山的侧面。这意味着一条非常长的车道。当我提到车道时，它并不能准确描述它是什么。对于这东西应该有另一个词。
During the winter, when Emilio and I would get home from school, the sun would be setting, and we'd struggle up to the house through drifted snow. My parents couldn't get the cars up, so they'd walk up and down carry supplies and groceries on a sled.
冬天，当埃米利奥和我从学校回家时，太阳正在落下，我们在漂流的雪中艰难地走向房子。我父母没法把车开上去，所以他们会走上走下，用雪橇搬运补给和杂货。
Once it was totally iced over, and we could barely walk up and down. For parts of the driveway, we literally had to crawl on our hands and knees.
有一次，它完全结冰了，我们几乎没法走上去或走下来。车道的某些路段，我们不得不真的是手脚并用地爬上去。
And I remember once-- and this seems straight out of some Arctic expedition. Late at night, Emilio and I were so tired, we tried to lie in the snowbanks to rest. My dad pulled on our arms and yelled at us to get up or we'd freeze to death. We all had to deal with that driveway, but it was the worst for my dad.
我记得有一次——这看起来简直像是北极探险。深夜，埃米利奥和我太累了，我们试图躺在雪堆里休息。爸爸拉着我们的胳膊，大声吼我们站起来，否则我们会冻死的。我们都必须应对那条车道，但对我爸爸来说这是最糟的。
There was one particular day when it snowed, and I really feel like something came over dad. It was like this battle with nature and that he was going to win. And he didn't. He started at the top. We must have been snowed in at the top. He started to shovel all the way down, and it took him hours, and hours, and hours. And, of course, it was still snowing, and it was very difficult to reason with him of your tracks are being totally covered, and this is kind of a blizzard, and it's windy.
有特别的一天，当它下雪时，我真的觉得有什么东西附在爸爸身上了。就像这与大自然的斗争，而且他要赢。但他没赢。他从顶端开始。我们一定是被困在了顶端的雪里。他开始一路铲到底，花了他几个小时，几个小时，几个小时。当然，雪还在下，而且很难跟他讲理，你的足迹完全被覆盖了，这简直是一场暴风雪，而且风很大。
I don't think he ever quite, quite got to the bottom. He was just exhausted and wiped out. And it was dark. And then when he trudged back up the hill, it was all blown over. It was a whole day's work that really, really did nothing.
我不认为他真的走到底了。他只是筋疲力尽，彻底累垮了。而且天黑了。然后当他费力地走回山上时，它又全被吹满了雪。那整整一天的劳动实际上，真的什么都没做。
It's amazing that with all the construction, and machinery, and my dad's general frenzy that he didn't kill himself. There was a series of accidents. He cut his nose on barbed wire, hammered his nose, fell off staging two times, broke several ribs, collapsed a lung, nearly ruptured his spleen. And then there was the worst of all.
令人惊奇的是，在所有的施工、机械和我爸爸那种普遍的狂热中，他居然没把自己弄死。发生了一系列事故。他的鼻子被铁丝网割伤，砸到了鼻子，从脚手架上摔下来两次，摔断了几根肋骨，肺部萎缩，脾脏几乎破裂。然后还有最糟糕的一次。
We had been out for the day, and we came back, and it was towards evening. It was dusk. And I decided that I should cut up some wood, so that the whole day shouldn't be just used up on frivolous stuff, that I should do some work. Because I was trying to keep myself very disciplined about getting a certain amount of work done. And I hadn't cut up enough wood. So I said I would just work on that a little bit. And I was trying to do it very fast because it was getting dark and I'd set myself a certain amount to do.
我们出去了一天，回来的时候已经是晚上了。是黄昏。我决定我应该切一些木头，这样整天就不应该只花在琐碎的事情上，我应该做点工作。因为我试图在完成一定量的工作方面保持非常自律。我还没有切够木头。所以我说我要在这上面多做一点。我试图做得非常快，因为天黑了，而且我给自己定了一定的量要做。
And I was just standing in the pile of wood, cutting, which is a bad way to do it. And kicking aside the cut end pieces as they dropped off. And my foot rolled on one of them, and I fell forward into the pile with the chainsaw out in front of me. The tip hit the pile and kicked back.
我当时就站在木头堆里切木头，这是个很糟的方法。一边踢开切断掉下来的端头。我的脚在其中一个上滚了一下，我带着电锯向前摔进了堆里。尖端撞到了堆，弹了回来。
And as I fell forward, it turned around, and the blade faced me. And it caught me under the chin.
当我向前摔倒时，它转了过来，锯刃对着我。它卡在我的下巴底下。
Oh, God.
噢，天哪。
Missing cutting my throat open by just inches. It would have been terr-- I mean, your life would have been completely different. I thought I'd cut my throat open.
离割开我的喉咙只差几英寸。这会是非常——我是说，你的人生会完全不同。我当时以为我割开了自己的喉咙。
I remember bits and pieces, and I remember the sort of ragged, pink flesh that hung under his chin.
我还记得一些碎片，我记得他下巴下面悬着的那些参差不齐的粉色皮肉。
That's my brother, Emilio. He's 25 now. He was about 5 at the time.
那是我弟弟，埃米利奥。他现在25岁了。当时他大概5岁。
And I remember mom packing towels against his neck and wringing out one of the towels before driving to the hospital.
我记得妈妈把毛巾压在他的脖子上，拧干其中一条毛巾，然后开车去医院。
Wringing out the blood?
拧干血吗？
Wringing out the blood, right. And I don't remember any specifics after that.
拧干血，对。我不记得之后有什么具体的细节了。
You don't remember him coming in and saying-- I remember him coming in the door with this hand over his neck and blood just gushing out. And he said, "Maddie, I cut myself."
你不记得他走进来，说——我记得他用这只手捂着脖子走进门，血不停地涌出来。他说，“麦迪，我把自己割伤了。”
Oh God.
噢，天哪。
It's just like-- that voice. Those words. Oh, God. It was so scary. I just thought-- what else could you think? Dad's going to die.
就像是——那个声音。那些词。噢，天哪。太可怕了。我当时想——你还能想什么？爸爸要死了。
Right.
对。
If my dad had his dream of a rural homestead, and my mom had her dream of being Earth Mother, and I had my Little House on the Prairie fantasy, what's interesting is that Emilio had no dream about our move to Maine. He was just four. And as best as any of us can figure, he was the only one of us who didn't see the whole experience through a romantic haze.
如果我爸爸有他的乡村宅基地梦，妈妈有她做“大地母亲”的梦想，而我有《草原小屋》的幻想，有趣的是埃米利奥对我们搬到缅因州没有任何梦想。他只有四岁。据我们所能了解到的，他是我们中唯一一个没有通过浪漫的雾霾看待整个经历的人。
By August that first summer, he was asking dad, "When are we going to go home?" Meaning home to our apartment in New York. And Dad had to tell him, "We are home."
那年夏天到了八月，他问爸爸，“我们什么时候回家？”意思是回我们在纽约的公寓。爸爸不得不告诉他，“我们就在家里。”
So I had an interesting discussion with dad about bravery, about bravery versus insanity. And was he crazy, or was he brave? Was he a hero, or was he insane? Where do you come down on that?
所以我跟爸爸就勇敢这件事进行了一场有趣的讨论，关于勇敢与疯狂。他疯了，还是勇敢？他是个英雄，还是个疯子？你对此怎么看？
It's very interesting because the framing of the question is very telling of your vision of him that I don't quite get for myself. I get it, but I hesitate to say that it's the little girl vision of the father. But it definitely is. I just don't remember him as being crazy or insane. Or what was the other choice, heroic?
这非常有趣，因为问题的构架非常能说明你对他的愿景，我对他自己却并不太能理解。我懂，但我犹豫是否要说那是小女孩对父亲的愿景。但绝对是。我只是不记得他是个疯子或疯狂。或者另一个选择是什么，英雄？
I remember spending a lot of time with him and being part of his everyday building of the house. Particularly, I remember lunches down at Sprowl Lumber and just a lot of time to just be with him. And just riding around in the green truck with him and sort of being his sidekick. And I never thought of him as heroic.
我记得花了很多时间和他在每天盖房子的过程中。特别是，我记得在斯普劳尔木材厂吃午饭，以及很多时间只是和他在一起。只是坐在绿色卡车里和他一起，算是他的跟班。我从未认为他是英雄。
Talking to Emilio, I was surprised. I hadn't really thought about this, but it's no accident that my mom called the book, Meema's Adventures. This was my dream, not Emilio's.
和埃米利奥谈话时，我很惊讶。我之前没真正想过这件事，但妈妈把这本书叫《米玛的冒险》绝非偶然。这是我的梦想，不是埃米利奥的。
So I read Meema's Adventures with mom. Do you want to hear a little bit from it?
所以我跟妈妈读了《米玛的冒险》。你想听听里面的一点内容吗？
Please, yeah.
请，好的。
OK. This is in the section when mom and dad are telling us that we're going to be leaving New York.
好的。这是在妈妈和爸爸告诉我们要离开纽约的那一部分。
And we're overjoyed, I'm sure.
我们一定很高兴吧。
And we are, actually. We are.
实际上，我们确实很高兴。
Interesting.
有趣。
We are overjoyed.
我们很高兴。
Revisionist history.
修正主义历史。
"'Oh, yay. Oh, this is so much fun.'" And then, "'Will we ever come back to the city to live?' Meema asked quietly turning to daddy. 'To be honest, sweetheart. I don't know. The city is a good place to live in and grow, and so is the country. We've been in the city for a long time, and life has been very happy.'
“‘噢，耶。噢，这太好玩了。’然后，‘我们会回到城市住吗？’米玛轻声问道，转头看向爸爸。‘老实说，亲爱的。我不知道。城市是一个生活和成长的好地方，乡下也是。我们在城市待了很长时间，生活一直非常幸福。’”
'It's cold in Maine,' said Emilio. 'I don't want to be cold.'
“‘缅因州很冷，’埃米利奥说。‘我不想冷。’”
'Yes, the winters in Maine are cold,' said daddy. 'But we'll have a good, hot wood stove for indoors and layers and layers of clothing for outdoors. You won't be cold, Emilio. You'll be snug as a bug.'
“‘是的，缅因州的冬天很冷，’爸爸说。‘但我们会有个好的、热的木柴炉在室内，室外穿一层又一层的衣服。你不会冷的，埃米利奥。你会暖和得像个虫子。’”
'I don't mind the winter. I really want to have some animals,' said Meema.
“‘我不介意冬天。我真的很想养些动物，’米玛说。”
'And a puppy?' asked Emilio.
“‘还有一只小狗？’埃米利奥问。”
'I think we surely could,' said mommy."
“‘我想我们肯定可以，’妈妈说。”
And daddy will run over it with the truck.
然后爸爸会用车把它压过去。
For Emilio and me, the move to Maine was the central fact of our childhood, one of the central forces shaping who we are. As we've grown up, we've found we both have our father's mania when it comes to taking on big projects. We've both worked ourselves, literally, to the point of injury.
对于埃米利奥和我来说，搬到缅因州是我们童年的核心事件，是塑造我们今天是谁的核心力量之一。随着我们长大，我们发现我们俩在进行大项目时都有我父亲的那种狂热。我们俩都真的把自己工作到受伤的地步。
As a teenager, Emilio tried to embrace rural life. He threw himself into rock climbing, got wilderness first aid certification, led hiking trips. He was as obsessive about rock climbing as my dad was about building the house.
作为青少年，埃米利奥试图拥抱乡村生活。他投入到攀岩中，获得了野外急救证书，领导徒步旅行。他像我爸爸盖房子一样沉迷于攀岩。
Here's another thing that I think about. Are we city kids? Are we country kids?
这是我想到的另一件事。我们是城市孩子？还是乡村孩子？
Oh, well, I definitely decided that I was a city kid at the height of my attempt to become a wilderness trip leader. And I was cultivating a very natural, adventurous personality at Swarthmore, and leading the rock climbing club, and going on lots of hikes. I skipped my final exam study period when I was 19, and I went to go for a weeklong hike somewhere in the Shenandoahs, I think. And about three days into it, I realized that against every instinct that I had and every wish that I had for myself to be a rugged outdoorsman that I was really a city kid. And it came out of nowhere.
噢，嗯，我在我试图成为野外领队的巅峰期，明确决定了我是个城市孩子。我在斯沃斯莫尔学院培养了一种非常自然、爱冒险的个性，领导攀岩俱乐部，去参加许多徒步旅行。我在19岁时跳过了期末考试复习期，去参加了一次为期一周的徒步旅行，我想是在谢南多厄。大约进行了三天后，我意识到尽管我所有的直觉和所有想成为一个粗犷户外探险家的愿望，我其实是个城市孩子。那感觉来得没来由。
And I remember feeling upset about it on par with the realization that I was possibly gay at 16. They were very similar, that moment at which your self-image and your self-knowledge have nothing to do with each other, in fact, are diametrically opposed. So I'm a city kid.
我记得对此感到沮丧，程度就像16岁时意识到自己可能是同性恋一样。它们非常相似，那一刻你对自己的形象和自我认知毫无关联，事实上，是截然对立的。所以我是一个城市孩子。
Emilio's moving back to New York to get his PhD in anthropology, just six blocks from where we lived on the Upper West Side, 460 miles away from our house in Maine.
埃米利奥搬回纽约去攻读人类学博士学位，离我们在上西区住的地方只有六个街区，离我们在缅因州的房子460英里远。
It feels like a person rather than a thing. It feels like a member of the family to me. I feel like I would be really heartbroken if it were sold. I'd be really heartbroken.
它感觉像是一个人，而不是一个东西。它对我来说感觉像是家庭的一员。我觉得如果它被卖掉，我会真的很心碎。我会真的很心碎。
I don't think there's any danger of anyone ever buying that house.
我认为永远不会有人去买那栋房子。
Stop. Or worse, what if someone bought the land and tore down the house?
停。或者更糟，如果有人买下土地拆了那房子呢？
Right, exactly.
对，确实。
I feel like I would fling myself upon the machinery. Do not, do not take the house.
我觉得我会把自己扔在机械上面。不要，不要拆房子。
Whereas I would feel in some way that I could finally get on with my life. There's the difference.
而我会在某种程度上感觉我终于可以开始我的生活了。这就是区别。
Meema Spadola's story about her family's move to Maine continues in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
米玛·斯帕多拉关于她家庭搬迁到缅因州的故事将在片刻后从国际公共广播电台继续播出，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we chose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Dream House. Parents who try to build a brighter future for their families, and what happens to them when they try. We continue with Meema Spadola's story about her parents' move to Maine, and what it did to their family.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选定一个主题，为你带来关于那个主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目是“梦幻之家”。那些试图为家庭建立更光明未来的父母们，以及当他们尝试时发生了什么。我们继续米玛·斯帕多拉关于她父母搬迁到缅因州的故事，以及它对他们家庭造成的影响。
Just pulled in the driveway here. Starting up the hill.
刚开进车道。开始上山。
To do this radio story, I went home to Maine for the first time in two years.
为了做这个广播故事，我两年来第一次回到了缅因州。
Oh my god, and there's the house. And dad's home. And just a honk to let him know I'm here.
噢，天哪，房子在那儿。爸爸在家。按一下喇叭让他知道我到了。
He's playing piano inside. I can hear him out here. Dad's totally oblivious. He's playing piano and doesn't even hear me even though I honked. I'm going to sneak in. And [UNINTELLIGIBLE] the back.
他在里面弹钢琴。我在这外面能听到。爸爸完全没察觉。他在弹钢琴，虽然我按了喇叭他都没听见。我要溜进去。还有[难以辨认]后面。
Hey, dad. You were totally oblivious playing the piano.
嘿，爸爸。你弹钢琴弹得完全没察觉。
How did you sneak up on me?
你是怎么溜到我身后的？
I honked. I honked from outside. You didn't hear me?
我按了喇叭。我在外面按了喇叭。你没听见吗？
While I was home, my dad and I talked constantly about the house, the move, the summer of 1976. We'd never talked this much about that time. We walked the boundaries of the 63 acres of land and visited all the old sites, where we put the tent, the outhouse.
在我家的时候，我和我爸爸一直在不断地谈论房子、搬家、1976年的那个夏天。我们以前从来没这么谈论过那段时光。我们走遍了63英亩土地的边界，参观了我们放帐篷、厕所的所有旧址。
Do you see the-- of course, you see the rope hanging from the tree. That was our swing.
你看到那个——当然，你看到了从树上垂下来的绳子。那是我们的秋千。
That was your swing, yeah. That limb is dead now. You wouldn't want to try swinging on it.
那是你们的秋千，是的。那根树枝现在枯了。你不会想尝试在上面荡秋千的。
No. Hey, did you know about the thing that Emilio and I-- what Emilio and I had, the squirrel house?
不。嘿，你知道埃米利奥和我有的那个东西吗，松鼠屋？
No, show me.
不，展示给我看。
It wasn't a real squirrel house. This was a game that we played. That while you were building your house, we were building our house. And we were the squirrel family, and it was right over here.
那不是真的松鼠屋。这是我们玩的一个游戏。在你盖房子的时候，我们在盖我们的房子。我们是松鼠家庭，它就在这儿。
Does it look familiar to you?
它看起来熟悉吗？
Sort of. There's this big flat rock--
有点。这儿有块大平石——
I asked dad to give me a tour of the house as it stands today. The porch in front is half completed, the floor is unfinished, Sheetrock isn't up in most rooms, the bathroom isn't done yet. And I guess I hadn't thought about this up until now, but it really embarrasses him.
我请爸爸带我参观一下现在的房子。前面的门廊盖了一半，地板没完工，大多数房间没装石膏板，浴室也没做好。我想我在这之前没想过这个问题，但这真的很让他尴尬。
These days my dad's an architect. He took pains to point out he's finished a lot of houses now, except this one.
如今我爸爸是一名建筑师。他特意指出他现在盖好了许多房子，除了这一栋。
And the stairs just have plywood treads. They don't have the oak treads on that they're supposed to get. And this little piece of wall here hasn't been sheetrocked yet. But I did run the wiring in it, so now I can put the Sheetrock on it.
楼梯只有胶合板踏板。它们没有应该有的橡木踏板。这块小墙面还没装石膏板。但我已经把线布在里面了，所以我现在可以把石膏板装上了。
I didn't have any walls on my bedroom until I was like 15.
我15岁之前卧室都没有墙。
Oh really?
噢真的吗？
Yeah.
对。
Oh my goodness. Oh, I'm sorry.
噢，我的天哪。噢，我很抱歉。
That's OK. I survived. And I didn't have a door for a long time. I have a door on my old room now. It doesn't have a doorknob. So when you close it, it just sort of closes, and then you have to wedge your fingers in and open it up.
没关系。我活下来了。而且我很久都没有门。我现在旧房间有门。它没有门把手。所以当你关上它时，它只是关上了，然后你必须把手指塞进去打开它。
So this is really going to be on the radio, huh?
所以这真的要在广播里播出，是吧？
Sure.
当然。
Thanks, Meema. I'm supposed to be an architect though. This is great advertisement for me. Can't even finish his own house.
谢谢，米玛。我可应该是个建筑师呢。这对我来说真是绝佳的广告。连他自己的房子都盖不完。
While I was home doing these interviews, there were a lot of times that my dad got uncomfortable. And I'm embarrassed to say that I didn't understand why, so I kept pushing him. And finally, after days of this, he told me something I never understood before. We shared this experience, the move to Maine, but we didn't see it the same way at all.
在我家做这些采访时，有很多次我爸爸感到不舒服。我很羞愧地说，我不明白为什么，所以我一直在逼他。最后，几天之后，他告诉了我一件我从未理解过的事情。我们分享了这次经历，搬到缅因州，但我们对它的看法完全不同。
Every time I talked about it as a heroic adventure, he'd just cringe. For years, he saw the move as a grim series of failures. He dropped out of college, and this was his biggest attempt to redeem himself, to make something of his own. And every snowstorm, broken-down car, every unfinished part of the house, every single crisis was a referendum on his character. No matter how desperately he struggled, things kept slipping out of his control. And even as I say this, I feel incredibly resistant to seeing it this way because it means that I have to reconstruct my entire heroic vision of my childhood.
每次我把它当作英雄式的冒险谈论时，他就会退缩。多年来，他一直把这次搬迁看作一系列令人沮丧的失败。他从大学退学，这是他救赎自己、做一些属于自己的事情的最大尝试。每一场暴风雪、抛锚的汽车、房子里每一个没完工的部分，每一场危机都是对他性格的公投。无论他如何绝望地挣扎，事情总是在不断滑出他的掌控。甚至在我说出这些话的时候，我对从这个角度看它感到无比抗拒，因为这意味着我必须重建我整个童年的英雄愿景。
One of the long-term effects that I sort of joke about and it's also true, is that you've set up this ideal of what a man should do that most men couldn't really live up to. And again, it's--
我常开玩笑说的长期影响之一，也确实是真的，那就是你设立了一个男人应该做什么的理想，大多数男人根本无法达到。再说了，这是——
Including me.
包括我。
What?
什么？
Including me.
包括我。
Including you, yeah.
包括你，是的。
Turns out my dad would be more comfortable if I didn't see him as the hero of an adventure story.
事实证明，如果我不把他看作探险故事里的英雄，爸爸会更舒服。
My agenda isn't to explode your myth, but you did ask me to give my version of it because you felt like you'd mythologized it.
我的目的不是拆穿你的神话，但你确实让我给出我的版本，因为你觉得你把它神话了。
It's funny. It's like people will ask me, well, what are your parents like? The fact is, you're not a big man. How tall are you, dad?
真有趣。就像人们会问我，嗯，你父母是什么样的人？事实是，你不是个大块头。你多高，爸爸？
5'7''.
5英尺7英寸。
Right, you're not a big guy. You're strong, you're muscular. But you're not this huge, macho guy. You were a math teacher. You played piano, but you were just the coolest dad ever. No, really. You were. You made a bicycle. You didn't make a bicycle for me, but remember that bike I got? The first bike? And you painted it red, and you wrote "Meema" on the side. You were just the coolest dad ever. You built us loft beds in Manhattan, and there was a swing in our room and a bar to swing on. And then you moved us up to Maine. It was like, how much cooler could you get than that?
对，你不是个大个子。你很强壮，肌肉发达。但你不是那种巨大、大男子主义的家伙。你是个数学老师。你会弹钢琴，但你简直是有史以来最酷的爸爸。不，真的。你是。你做了个自行车。你没给我做个自行车，但记得我有的那个车吗？第一辆自行车？你把它漆成红色，还在侧面写了“米玛”。你是有史以来最酷的爸爸。你在曼哈顿给我们盖了阁楼床，房间里有个秋千，还有一个可以荡的杆子。然后你把我们搬到了缅因州。感觉就像，你还能有多酷？
That's nice to hear. That's really nice to hear. I didn't know that. Oh, you wanted to know where the outhouse was?
听到这个真好。真的很好。我不知道。噢，你想知道厕所在哪儿？
Yes.
是的。
So we walked to see where the outhouse was. But the structure was gone, and the hole was filled in, healed over like it never existed.
所以我们走过去看厕所在哪儿。但结构已经不见了，洞也被填平了，愈合得好像它从未存在过一样。
My dad told me he doesn't want to be judged on that one period in our lives when we moved to Maine.
我爸爸告诉我，他不想被判定在我们生命中的那个时期，也就是我们搬到缅因州的时候。
And I certainly don't want to say this was my life, building this house. A life is many things. There's a lot to it. It's having children, and raising children, and the work I've done, and all kinds of things. My relationships, friends, my whole life.
我当然不想说这就是我的生活，建造这所房子。生活是很多事情。它有很多内容。是拥有孩子，抚养孩子，我所做的工作，和各种各样的事情。我的人际关系，朋友，我整个人生。
So we're breaking down the-- I guess in some ways maybe I need to diffuse the importance that this has had. Do you know what I mean?
所以我们要打破——我想在某种程度上也许我需要扩散它的重要性。你知道我的意思吗？
Perhaps.
也许吧。
Well, just because it happened at such an important time, and it was like, this was my childhood. I don't have many memories before a time when this was happening. This is what I'm from. This is what I come from. It's this house. It was like this family member. Really, it was so present.
嗯，只是因为它发生在如此重要的时间，就像，这是我的童年。在这件事发生之前，我没有多少记忆。这就是我的来源。我来自这里。就是这栋房子。它就像这家庭的一员。真的，它太显眼了。
But that's you. And I don't know that you have to necessarily debunk a myth or anything like that to move on. But for me, what would it be like for me if I just stayed with this as if this is the essential thing about me and I didn't do anything else? What would that be like?
但那是你。我不知道你是否一定要拆穿神话才能继续前进。但对我来说，如果我就留在这里，好像这是关于我的本质东西，而我没做别的事情，那会是什么样？那会是什么样？
Then that would be super obsessive.
那会超级狂热的。
And it's just not sufficient either. It's not enough for me. And for me, we had a different experience of it. And now, for me, I live in it. It's just a common place. It doesn't have any of this mythical aura about it.
而且那也不够。对我来说不够。对我来说，我们对它有不同的体验。现在，对我来说，我住在这里。这只是一个普通的地方。它没有任何这种神话般的氛围。
I don't think that's entirely true. For years, he couldn't work on the house. He just stopped. Like if he stopped trying, he'd stop failing. But over the course of talking about this for weeks while I put together this story, something changed. It happened after he told me about feeling like he'd failed.
我认为那不完全正确。多年来，他没法继续盖房子。他只是停了下来。好像如果他不再尝试，他就不会再失败。但在几周谈论这件事、我整理这个故事的过程中，事情改变了。这发生在他告诉我关于感到自己失败的事情之后。
Somehow after that conversation, it felt like there wasn't anything more to say about that time. And for the first time in years, my dad started working on the house again. He called me the other night. He says he's already finished the bathroom, put in a beautiful tile floor, replaced the ugly, old toilet. Sheetrock is going up.
不知何故在谈话之后，感觉关于那段时间没什么好说的了。多年来第一次，我爸爸开始再次盖房子了。他前几天晚上给我打了电话。他说他已经完工了浴室，铺了漂亮的瓷砖地板，换掉了丑陋的旧马桶。石膏板正在装上去。
Meema Spadola is a documentary filmmaker living in New York, an hour subway ride from where she was born.
米玛·斯帕多拉是一位纪录片制片人，住在纽约，离她出生的地方有一小时地铁路程。
Act Two, Blue Sky Dream.
第二幕，“蓝天梦”。
Ronald Reagan made my family's tract home into a dream home. Just about the time of his landslide reelection in 1984, Ronald Reagan knocked out the north and west facing walls of our house. He tore out the linoleum floor and the flocked ceiling of the family room. Ronald Reagan gave my mother a kitchen twice the area of the old one. He gave my father a shop of his own just off the garage. He got rid of--
罗纳德·里根把我们家的联排房变成了梦幻之家。大约在他1984年压倒性连任时，罗纳德·里根拆掉了我们家向北和向西的墙。他拆掉了油地毡地板和家庭室的植绒天花板。罗纳德·里根给了我妈妈一个旧厨房两倍大的厨房。他给了我爸爸一个车库旁边的他自己的工作室。他摆脱了——
That's David Beers reading from his memoir, Blue Sky Dream. Ronald Reagan built his family dream house by funding the strategic defense initiative, Star Wars. David Beers' father was an aerospace engineer. And back in 1957, after the Russian satellite Sputnik scared the nation into a new defense industry boom, Beers' family joined tens of thousands of others who went to work in aerospace in northern California. Beers' father worked at Lockheed on secret defense projects through the Cold War and the Vietnam War.
那是大卫·比尔斯在阅读他的回忆录《蓝天梦》。罗纳德·里根通过资助战略防御计划——“星球大战”来建造他家庭的梦幻之家。大卫·比尔斯的父亲是一名航空航天工程师。早在1957年，在俄国的卫星“斯普特尼克”惊吓全国进入一个新的国防工业繁荣时期后，比尔斯一家加入了成千上万去北加州从事航空航天工作的家庭。比尔斯的父亲在冷战和越战期间在洛克希德公司从事秘密国防项目。
Those these days the suburbs get criticized as a place of sheer materialism, Beers writes that it was not materialism that was attractive to his family when they moved out to the California suburbs. It was the emptiness of the place. It was the fact that you could create new, modern lives out there, hopeful lives, crafting new traditions.
尽管这些天郊区被批评为纯粹的唯物主义场所，比尔斯写道，当他的家人搬到加州郊区时，吸引他们的并不是唯物主义。而是那个地方的空旷。事实是，你可以从那里创造新的、现代的生活，充满希望的生活，创造新的传统。
He writes that, at one point, his mother actually decided that the family was Irish even though, really, they were only one-fourth Irish.
他写道，有一次，他妈妈决定全家是爱尔兰人，尽管事实上，他们只有四分之一的爱尔兰血统。
But let's not let those facts get in the way. My mother decided that a fun thing to be was an Irish Catholic, and so she was determined to invent this Irishness for us in the middle of Mediterranean California. And so there were leprechauns living in our oleanders. And on Saint Patrick's Day, we all lined up, and our mother clipped to our little Catholic school, red sweaters these green buttons that said, "Kiss me, I'm Irish" and shamrocks with blarney stones. And she avoided altogether some of the other stereotypes of Irishness, the idea of the morose, heavy drinker.
但让我们别让这些事实阻碍。我妈妈决定做一个爱尔兰天主教徒是件有趣的事，所以她决心在加州的地中海中间为我们发明这种爱尔兰身份。于是我们的夹竹桃里住着小精灵。圣帕特里克节那天，我们都排好队，妈妈在我们的小天主教学校红色毛衣上别上绿色的徽章，上面写着，“吻我，我是爱尔兰人”，还有带有“巧言石”的三叶草。而她完全避开了爱尔兰身份的其他刻板印象，那种忧郁、重度饮酒者的想法。
So she'd just select the parts she liked?
所以她只是挑选她喜欢的部分？
Well, that was the great thing about the suburbs in California and anywhere else in the country where this great federal investment in the Cold War infrastructure was going on. These were brand new places. There was the opportunity to invent a culture, and you constructed that culture with what you had available to you.
嗯，这就是加州郊区和其他任何正在进行大规模联邦冷战基础设施投资的地区最棒的地方。这些都是全新的地方。有机会创造一种文化，你用你现有的东西来构建那种文化。
Can I ask you to talk for a minute ago about how you saw your dad when you were a kid? In your book, in your memoir, you describe him in scene after scene as showing up with lumber, and building stuff, and laying down new brick walkways, and building a deck behind the house, and constantly having one project after another. You write at one point, "There was nothing my father could not do himself apparently."
我可以请你谈谈你小时候是怎么看你爸爸的吗？在你的书中，你的回忆录里，你在场景接场景中描述他带着木材出现，建造东西，铺设新的砖路，在房后盖露台，不停地有一个接一个的项目。你在一个点写道，“显然没有什么是父亲自己做不到的。”
He wasn't always successful. I think he spent maybe six months designing the sprinkler system for the backyard. And when he finally turned it on, it was wondrous to behold. The rain birds all swept around in their perfect arcs and what have you. But the grass didn't grow. As it turned out, he had picked the wrong seed for the soil, and the water didn't fully cover the ground. And as it turned out, much like aerospace itself, he had to keep going back and revising his plans. And he went terribly over budget. But in the end, he got the grass to grow. And that was the main message there, which is that through technology and perseverance, you can accomplish anything.
他并不总成功。我想他花了也许六个月时间设计后院的喷灌系统。当他终于打开它时，那景象令人惊叹。雨鸟们完美地扫过弧线等等。但草没长出来。事实证明，他为土壤选错了种子，水没能完全覆盖地面。事实证明，就像航空航天本身一样，他必须不断回去修正他的计划。而且他严重超支。但最终，他让草长了出来。而那才是主要信息，即通过技术和毅力，你可以完成任何事。
Well, you've agreed to read a long excerpt from your book, Blue Sky Dream. You write about in the book what you call your "tribe," the aerospace workers and their families, moving into a valley that was first known as the Valley of Heart's Delight, building a home in a brand new subdivision with the Old World name Clarendon Manor.
好吧，你已经同意朗读你书中关于《蓝天梦》的一大段摘录。你在书中写到了你所谓的“部落”，航空航天工作者及其家庭，搬进了一个最初被称为“心之喜悦谷”的山谷，在一个全新的、名字具有老世界色彩的 subdivision“克拉伦登庄园”里盖了家。
Whenever I think of the house they bought and the development surrounding it, the earliest images that come to mind are of an ascetic barrenness to the streets. The snapshots confirm it.
每当我想起他们买的那栋房子和周围的开发项目，脑海中浮现出的最早的图像是街道的那种苦行僧般的荒凉。快照证实了这一点。
There I am with my new friends around a picnic table in the backyard. Shirtless boys with mouths full of birthday cake. In the backyard, nothing but implanted dirt, a stripe of redwood fence, stucco, an open sky. That was the emptiness being chased by thousands of other young families to similar backyards in various raw corners of the nation.
那是我和我的新朋友在后院的野餐桌旁。没穿上衣的男孩嘴里塞满了生日蛋糕。后院里除了植入的泥土，只有一条红木栅栏的条纹，灰泥，一片开阔的蓝天。那就是成千上万个年轻家庭在全国各地原始角落的类似后院里追逐的空旷。
"Didn't the sterility scare the hell out of you?" I've often asked my mother. "Didn't you look around and wonder if you'd been stuck on a desert island?" The questions never phase her.
“那种单调没吓坏你吗？”我经常问我妈。“你没四处看并想知道你是否被困在一个荒岛上了吗？”这些问题从来没让她动摇。
"We were thrilled to death, not afraid at all. Everyone else was moving in at the same time as us. It was a whole new adventure for us. For everyone." Everyone was arriving with a sense of forward momentum joined. Everyone was taking courage from the sight of another orange moving van pulling in next door. A family just like us unloading pole lamps and cribs and Formica dining tables like our own. Having been given the emptiness we longed for, there lay ahead the task of pouring meaning into the vacuum.
“我们兴奋得要死，一点也不害怕。其他人都在和我们同时搬进来。这对我们所有人来说都是一个全新的冒险。”每个人都带着一种共同的前进动力到达。每个人都在看到隔壁邻居拉进另一辆橙色搬家车时获得了勇气。一个像我们一样的家庭，像我们一样卸下落地灯、婴儿床和福米卡餐桌。在被赋予了我们渴望的空旷之后，摆在面前的任务是将意义注入真空。
We were blithe conquers, my tribe. When we chose a new homeland, invaded a place, settled it, and made it over in our image, we did so with the smiling sense of our own inevitability. At first, we would establish a few outposts, a Pentagon-funded research university, say, or a bomber command center, or a missile testing range. And then, over the next decade or two, we would arrive by the thousands and tens of thousands until nothing looked or felt as it had before. Yet whenever we sent our advance teams to someplace like the Valley of Heart's Delight, we did not cause panic in the populace. More likely, a flurry of joyous meetings of the Chambers of Commerce and Rotary clubs. You could understand then why families like mine tended to behave with a certain hubris.
我们是无忧无虑的征服者，我的部落。当我们选择一个新的家园，入侵一个地方，定居并以我们的形象重塑它时，我们带着一种我们自己必然性的微笑感觉。起初，我们会建立一些前哨，五角大楼资助的研究大学，或者一个轰炸机指挥中心，或者一个导弹试验场。然后，在接下来的十年或二十年里，我们会成千上万地到来，直到没有东西看起来或感觉起来和以前一样。然而，每当我们派遣我们的先遣队去像“心之喜悦谷”这样的地方时，我们并没有在民众中引起恐慌。更有可能的是，商会和扶轮社的一阵欢庆会议。那时你就能明白为什么像我这样的家庭往往表现得有点狂妄自大。
In the spring of 1962, the Valley of Heart's Delight was covered with blossoms. Back then the cherry and plum and apricot trees would froth so white and pink that driving around the place felt like burrowing through cotton candy. Spanish colonizers had planted the first of these glades.
1962年的春天，“心之喜悦谷”被花朵覆盖。那时樱花、李花和杏树会开得那么白、那么粉，开车到处走感觉就像在穿过棉花糖。西班牙殖民者种植了第一批这些林地。
On warm evenings in the spring of 1962, this is what my father and mother would do. After dinner, they would place my baby sister in her stroller, and the four of us would set out from the small, used house they were renting in an established subdivision, already half a dozen years old, named Strawberry Park. We would walk six blocks and run out of sidewalk. We would pick up a wide trail cut a foot and a half deep into the adobe ground, a winding road bed of waiting blacktop.
在1962年春天的温暖夜晚，这就是我爸爸妈妈会做的事情。晚饭后，他们会把我的小妹妹放在婴儿车里，我们四个人会从他们租的一栋小而旧的房子出发，在那栋房子里一个已经成立半打年的分开发区，名叫“草莓园”。我们会走六个街区，然后人行道就到头了。我们会踏上一条在 adobe 土里切下英尺半深的宽阔小路，一条蜿蜒的等待铺设柏油的路基。
At a certain point, we would leave the road bed and make our way across muddy clay that was crosshatched by tractor treads, riven by pipe trenches. We would marvel at the cast concrete sewer sections lying about, gray, knee-scratching barrels big enough for me to crawl inside. We would breathe in the sap scent of two-by-fours stacked around us, the smell of plans ready to go forward.
在某个点，我们会离开路基，穿过被拖拉机履带交叉划过、被管道沟壑撕裂的泥泞粘土。我们会惊叹于躺在那里的铸造混凝土下水道部分，灰色的、刮膝盖的圆桶，大得足以让我爬进去。我们会呼吸周围堆积的木材发出的树液气味，准备向前推进的计划的味道。
Finally, we would arrive at our destination, a collection of yellow and red ribbons tied to small wooden stakes sprouting in the mud. These markers identified the outline of lot 242 of unit 6 of track 3113, exactly 14,500 square feet of emptiness that now belonged to us.
最终，我们会到达目的地，一堆扎在泥土里发芽的小木桩上的黄色和红色丝带。这些标记标出了3113地块6单元242号地块的轮廓，正好是14500平方英尺的属于我们的空地。
All around the outline were piles of cherry and plum and apricot trees, their roots ripped from the ground. The spring blossoms still clinging to their tangled-up branches.
轮廓周围是一堆堆被从地上拔出的樱花、李花和杏树，它们的根。春天的花朵仍然挂在它们缠绕在一起的树枝上。
Our rite evolved with the season. Early on, my father would go from stake to yellow-ribboned stake, telling us where the kitchen would be, where the front door would go, which windows would be getting the most sun. Later, after the concrete foundation and plywood subflooring were in and the skeletons of walls were up, we would wander through the materializing form of our home, already inhabiting with our imaginations its perfect potentiality.
我们的仪式随着季节而演变。早些时候，我父亲会从一根木桩走到下一根扎着黄丝带的木桩，告诉我们厨房会在哪儿，前门会去哪儿，哪扇窗户会得到最多的阳光。后来，在混凝土基础和胶合板底层地板铺好，墙壁的骨架立起来之后，我们会在我们家成型的结构中穿行，已经在我们的想象中居住着它完美的潜力。
Within a decade after the coming of aerospace to the Valley of Heart's Delight, developers were shelling out nearly $100,000 per acre for any land left that might still be covered with blossoms. This should give an idea of the quiet force my people exerted whenever they entered a place. Power enough to undo a century-old economy and strip the blossoms from a valley once and for all.
在航空航天工业来到“心之喜悦谷”后的十年内，开发商们为任何可能仍然覆盖着花朵的剩余土地每英亩支付近10万美元。这应该能让人了解我的人民每进入一个地方所施加的那种安静的力量。足以撤销一个百年历史的经济并永久地剥去一个山谷的花朵的力量。
My people did sigh at the extinction of those blossoms. But honestly, we did not mourn their disappearance in any deeply felt way. Certainly, we didn't feel guilt. We had not, after all, come to the Valley of Heart's Delight to join the circular rhythm of nature. Our imagination was linear, proceeding forward and upward. And our lines did not curve back on themselves, as did the seasons. We saw promise in the clean possibilities that arose once every blossom had been erased, never to return.
我的人民确实为那些花朵的灭绝叹息。但老实说，我们并没有以任何深刻的方式哀悼它们的消失。当然，我们没有感到内疚。毕竟，我们来到“心之喜悦谷”并不是为了加入大自然的循环节奏。我们的想象是线性的，向前和向上进行。我们的线并没有像季节那样弯曲回来。我们在每朵花被擦掉、永不复返后产生的清洁可能性中看到了希望。
Several valleys over from ours, Joan Didion watched the coming of my tribe with dread. We moved her to write, in a 1965 essay, how it felt to be a native daughter. To have come from a family who has always been in the Sacramento Valley and to see that the boom was on and the voice of the aerospace engineer would be heard in the land. 15,000 aerospace workers, almost all of them imported, had arrived on the outskirts of Sacramento to join Aerojet General, a maker of missile boosters.
在我们所在的山谷的几个山谷之外，琼·迪迪安带着恐惧看着我的部落的到来。1965年的一篇散文促使她写下了作为一名本土女儿是什么感觉。拥有一个一直都在萨克拉门托谷的家庭，并看到繁荣正在到来，航空航天工程师的声音将在大地上被听到。15000名航空航天工作者，几乎全部是进口的，已经抵达萨克拉门托郊区加入导弹助推器制造商Aerojet General。
Joan Didion's family was, like the orchard people of the Valley of Heart's Delight, a family tied to agriculture with 100 years of circular rhythms behind them. Hers were a people primly insular and tragic-minded, according to the native daughter. Her valley was a place where incautious children visiting from out of town often would drown in the river, disappear forever. And the old locals would see a proper lesson in that, would say, as Joan Didion's grandmother did, "They were from away. Their parents had no business letting them in the river."
琼·迪迪安的家庭，像“心之喜悦谷”的果园人一样，是一个与农业相连、有100年循环节奏的家庭。根据这位本土女儿的说法，她的人民是古板且悲剧性的。她的山谷是一个来自城外的粗心大意的孩子经常会淹死在河里、永远消失的地方。而当地的老人们会从中看到一个恰当的教训，会说，正如琼·迪迪安的祖母所说，“他们是从远方来的。他们的父母没道理让他们进河。”
In another essay written five years later, Didion gets at the profound difference between her people and mine. She writes of "growing up convinced that the heart of darkness lies in not some error of social organization, but in man's own blood." She reveals herself, in other words, to be a pessimist about human endeavour, engineered and executed on a grand scale. How different from my tribe who would say instead, "If incautious children might drown in a river, let us erect a cyclone fence. Even drive the river underground, leaving behind a manufactured surface that was dry and safe, empty, and speaking of promise." That, after all, is what was done with the creek the ran by Clarendon Manor.
在五年后写的另一篇散文中，迪迪安触及了她的人民和我的人民之间巨大的区别。她写道：“在成长过程中坚信黑暗的心所在之处，不是某种社会组织的错误，而是在人自己的血中。”换句话说，她揭示了自己是一个关于人类努力的悲观主义者，经过工程设计并在大规模上执行。与我的部落截然不同，我的部落会说：“如果粗心大意的孩子可能会淹死在河里，让我们竖起一道旋风栅栏。甚至把河流驱动到地下，留下一个干燥、安全、空旷且述说着希望的人造表面。”毕竟，这就是对流经克拉伦登庄园的小溪所做的事。
Within 10 years of my family's arrival, the Valley of Heart's Delight was no longer green. It had become a vast matrix of expressways, and freeways, and Clarendon Manors, a vast matrix of companies making technology primarily for the government. The population had grown many times over in those 10 years, and we no longer heard the Valley of Heart's Delight called that anymore. In fact, no one I knew had ever used that sentimental name. While I was growing up, my family simply had called it "The Valley." Or as it was officially termed on the government studies in the plans of various developers, "the Santa Clara Valley." It would not be until a time distant, well into the 1970s, that we would begin calling our home "Silicon Valley."
在我家到来后的10年内，“心之喜悦谷”不再是绿色的了。它已经变成了一个巨大的高速公路和克拉伦登庄园的矩阵，一个主要为政府生产技术的巨大公司矩阵。那10年里人口增长了许多倍，我们不再听到“心之喜悦谷”被称为那个名字了。事实上，我认识的没有人曾用过那个感伤的名字。在我成长过程中，我的家庭只是简单地称它为“山谷”。或者正如它在各开发商计划的政府研究中所正式术语的那样，“圣克拉拉谷”。直到很久以后的1970年代，我们才会开始把我们的家称为“硅谷”。
There was yet another rite of spring practiced by my family, a rite that became possible once the invasion of my tribe was all but complete, once nearly all the blossoms had been replaced by settlements like our own.
我的家庭还有另一种春天的仪式，一种在我的部落的入侵几乎完成，几乎所有的花朵都被像我们这样的定居点取代后成为可能的仪式。
On an evening that was bright and windy, but too warm to be winter anymore, my father would come home from Lockheed with a kite or two, balsa sticks wrapped tightly with colorful tissue paper. If the next morning was a Saturday, he would put the kites together for us. Tear us a tail from an old sheet, make a string bridle that held the kite just so. Help us launch the kite, and send it up over the tract homes. For just this very purpose, my father kept what seemed a mile of twine on an enormous spool. And so the kite would climb higher and higher until it became a shimmying dot against the blue.
在一个明亮多风的傍晚，但太热而不可能是冬天了，我爸爸会带着一两个风筝从洛克菲勒下班回家，用彩纸紧紧包裹的轻木条。如果第二天早上是星期六，他会帮我们组装风筝。从旧床单上给我们撕下一个尾巴，做一个把风筝固定的线衔。帮我们放风筝，把它送向联排房的上空。正是为了这个目的，我爸爸在一个巨大的线轴上保留了似乎有一英里长的麻绳。于是风筝飞得越来越高，直到它变成了蓝天下一个抖动的点。
At that point, my father would go into his garage and make a small parachute. He would unfold a paper napkin and tie its corners to four strands of string, drawing the other ends of the string together, and knotting them around a bolt for weight. He would stick a bit of reinforcing tape in the center of the napkin and pass through that a bent pin, making a hook that poked out of the top of the parachute.
在那一点上，我爸爸会进车库做一个小降落伞。他会展开一张纸巾，把它的四个角系在四股线上，把线的另一端拉在一起，打结绕在一个螺栓上以增加重量。他会在纸巾中心贴一小块加固胶带，穿过它一个弯曲的别针，做一个从降落伞顶部露出来的钩子。
Next, my father would write our phone number on the parachute with the words, "If found, please call."
接下来，我爸爸会在降落伞上写下我们的电话号码，上面写着“如果找到，请拨打”。
"Ready for take off?" my father would say, as he grabbed hold of the taut kite string. And then a miraculous thing would happen. Driven by the wind, the parachute would skitter up the line, joining the kite high in the sky in what seemed an instant. When it reached the top, my father would say, "Give her a jerk." And the parachute would fall away from the kite and drift in whichever direction the wind was blowing, until we could see it no longer.
“准备起飞了吗？”当我爸爸抓住绷紧的风筝线时，他会说。然后一件奇迹般的事情发生了。在风的驱动下，降落伞会沿着线滑上去，瞬间加入了高空中的风筝。当它到达顶部时，我爸爸会说，“拽她一下。”降落伞就会脱离风筝，向风吹的方向漂流，直到我们再也看不见它。
Then we'd begin the wait for the phone to ring. The wait for someone to call and say they had our parachute. If hours went by, my mother might suggest a prayer to Saint Anthony, finder of lost items. "Tony, Tony, listen, listen. Hurry, hurry. Something's missing. You have to believe."
然后我们开始等待电话铃响。等待有人打电话说他们捡到了我们的降落伞。如果过了几个小时，妈妈可能会建议向失物招领者圣安东尼祈祷。“托尼，托尼，听着，听着。快快。有东西不见了。你必须相信。”
If we said the prayer and did believe, the ring would come, and someone would say, "Got your-- I guess it's a parachute here. Landed in my backyard. Almost ran over it with the mower."
如果我们说了祷告并且相信了，铃声就会响起，有人会说，“拿到你的——我猜是降落伞在这儿。落在我后院了。差点被割草机压到。”
My father would write down the address, and he would get out the street map. He would pinpoint our destination, and we older kids would set off on our Stingray bikes, having been given a reason to trace a route we never would have traced otherwise, so empty and so much the same was every street for miles around. We would leave our cul-de-sac named Pine Hill Court, where there was neither a pine nor a hill, and we would pedal far beyond Springwood Drive and past Happy Valley Way, ending up in some cul-de-sac we had not known existed. And there would be a man about my father's age with a similarly receding hairline and knit sport shirt. A man who seemed to be pleased at the serendipitous fun our parachute had brought into his Saturday. A man who safely could be assumed to do blue sky work for a living.
我爸爸会写下地址，拿出街道地图。他会标出我们的目的地，我们这些大孩子会骑上我们的 Stingray 自行车出发，因为我们有理由追踪一条我们原本永远不会追踪的路线，因为每条街道在几英里内都如此空旷且一模一样。我们会离开名为“松树山苑”的死胡同，那里既没有松树也没有山，我们会骑到“春木大道”以外和“快乐谷路”过去，最终停在一个我们不知道存在的死胡同里。那儿会有一个和我父亲年纪相仿的男人，有着同样后移的发际线和针织运动衫。一个似乎对我们的降落伞带入他周六的偶然乐趣感到高兴的男人。一个可以安全假设靠蓝天工作生活的人。
Anywhere we cared to drop a parachute from the sky, there would be someone like him. A house and a family like his, and like ours.
任何我们想从天上扔下降落伞的地方，都会有像他这样的人。一个像他那样、像我们那样的房子和家庭。
David Beers' memoir is Blue Sky Dream .
大卫·比尔斯的回忆录是《蓝天梦》。
Well, the vocal stylings of Mr. John Wayne. Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and me with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Music help today from Mr. John Connors. Today's program was first broadcast back during the 20th century, all the way back in 1997.
好吧，约翰·韦恩先生的声乐风格。我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德参与。约翰·康纳斯先生今天提供音乐帮助。今天的节目首播于20世纪，回溯到1997年。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can get our free weekly podcast and listen to old shows online for absolutely free.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费获得我们每周的播客，并绝对免费地在线收听旧节目。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who's going to buy you a puppy--
WBEZ节目管理由托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他会给你买一只小狗——
And daddy will run over it with the truck.
然后爸爸会用车把它压过去。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带着更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。